- All right.
(audience claps)
We usually end the show as
something from the internet
but today we've got
something a little scary.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Halloween Horror Nights is in full swing
here at Universal (thunder cracks) Studios
Oh (beep)
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I don't do, I don't do scary.
And you know this.
(audience laughs)
You all know this! (laughs)
Okay. I didn't know that was happening.
All right.
I'm hot.
Okay.
Our very own warmup guy Rubin Ervin
actually got his start
at Halloween Horror nights in Orlando.
I did not know that.
So come on down, Rubin
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- Okay.
(laughs) (audience claps)
- I didn't know about that either.
- You are a liar!
- I promise you I didn't know!
- Okay I did not know either.
- I promise.
- Okay. Wait.
So this year the park says
that they brought the together
kind of the "sickest minds"
in horror to immerse you in a living,
breathing, three
dimensional world of terror.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- So we asked you to check
out Halloween Horror Nights.
- Yeah.
- Cuz they knew I wasn't going to.
(audience laughs)
- And last weekend you did.
So what's changed in the last 15 years?
- Okay. When I started off, it felt
like I was part of a
high school production.
- Okay.
- This is a Broadway production, okay!
Everything is bigger,
everything is brighter.
Everything is so much more scary.
Like I did chainsaw.
But now they have like
clown faces, chainsaw
people running at you and I
mean, they are all up on you.
All right!
And I gotta tell you, it's scary.
It's as scary as humanly possible.
If you are the type of
person that does not like
super scary things,
I advise you to buy a
ticket, walk in the park,
cover your eyes, and
then beeline to the bar.
And just stay there.
Just stay at the bar.
- That's looking out.
(Rubin and audience laughs)
That's looking out.
Is there anything besides the
bar that's for me about that?
- I'm gonna give you two pieces of advice.
- Okay.
- One thing you don't wanna do
is the Scarecrow Corn House.
Cause you walk in
and it's like a jump
scare every 30 seconds.
- [Kelly] Nope.
- [Rubin] You walk in, there's like,
they feel like spiders on you.
Don't go there!
If you are super, super
scary, like I know you are.
Cause the werewolf scared
the bejesus out of you
- Yeah I don't like things.
- If you don't like that, all right.
Go to Potter all right, go to Potter
They have like-
- [Kelly] Harry Potter?
- Yes go to Harry Potter.
- [Kelly] This is my wheelhouse.
- [Rubin] Yes. They have the Death Eaters.
They're not that scary,
and you can do that with Butter Bear.
So it's amazing.
- And it's called a Death Eater!
It's kind of scary.
Don't do it again.
- I am very black.
What's happening?
(scary music) (woman screams)
- What the hell?
- No, I didn't know this.
- No!
girl, girl, girl.
I don't do it.
I don't get...
Mama does not do it.
Mama don't do it.
- No, we're good, we're good, we're good
we're good, we're good, we're good
we're good.
- Oh my Gosh.
- I'm gonna go this way, Kelly!
- Thank you, Rubin.
(audience cheers)
Okay. I'm liking your post right now.
That's not all,
our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of G2
The go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
wants to honor truly unstoppable people
like the Chainsaw Squad.
Sure! (audience laughs)
We've hidden a spine chilling check
for a thousand dollars
under somebody's chair.
So check your chairs people.
(drum roll)
Now I saw a lot of doubt.
Y'all don't look like you're
at Christmas and you're getting in there.
(audience laughs)
- [Woman] That's okay!
- Kelly! It's me!
- Oh, it is?
- Yeah!
(audience cheers) (guitar music)
Hi. I don't do scary
either. This isn't my thing.
- You don't do look for money well either.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
What's your name?
Where are you from?
- I'm Jayden. I'm from San
Diego and today's my birthday.
- [Cameraman] Yay!
- Happy Birthday.
(audience cheers)
That's exciting.
You get a thousand
dollars and some creeps.
(audience cheers)
Yeah!
- Thank you. Oh my gosh.
I don't even know what
to do. Thank you so much.
- Well have so much fun with
the money. (Kelly laughs)
- Thank you.
- All right.
Whether you wanna be
scared, I don't know why,
but whether you wanna be scared
or just drink at the bar.
This Scarifying event runs select nights
through Monday, October 31st.
So go do it. (audience laughs)
Universal Studios Hollywood features eight
Frightening Haunted Houses,
and Universal Orlando Resort
has 10. More likely to
have a heart attack
there. (audience laughs)
So thanks to all our guests
today (audience cheers)
Chelsea Handler, Lindsey
Vonn, Wolfgang Puck,
Julia Tosha and Greg.
Ya'll have a great day,
and if it's not try and change it.